there's some other crimes
going around our culture and a lot of
people are defending those crimes
there's a documentary out from Vice the
left-wing Magazine Media Company
in which Libs make an argument
explicitly that they've been making
implicitly for many many years namely
that if you if you criticize crime
you're actually criticizing a race and a
culture
statistically it is true that Asians
right on average make more money like in
terms of medium make more money better
test scores get into better colleges all
that stuff I think the question is why
is that and I don't know if model
minority whatever that label wants
that's actually a myth because we cannot
be um well no listen well let me finish
my point we need to observe what makes
people successful and unsuccessful and I
think when you look at trends that are
generally true in the Asian Community
not of everyone but are generally true
usually you have families that are
sticking together you have
um you know people are taught to work
hard in school not get into trouble I
think that translates to why Asians on
Master are successful and I don't think
you have to be Asian or white for that
matter to not have kids out of wedlock
not you know commit crime not not cause
trouble or whatever it is it's just a
matter of like well common sense that's
what makes people successful and if
that's so-called assimilation having a
nuclear family buying a house going to
school whatever it is then yeah okay
call me a pro simile then I think
there's a difference between
assimilation and Erasure yes
yes there it is right there at the end
throughout the whole clip if you were
only listening to it you weren't able to
watch the just beautiful Expressions on
the faces of all the libs on the panel
he says you know I just think probably
people shouldn't have kids at a wedlock
and they should get married and they
should do well in school and they should
not commit crimes and you look on the
people's faces they say oh is he really
is is he really telling people not to
commit crimes is he oh my gosh what is
he and then at the end at the very very
tail end of that clip you get the thrust
of the libs argument they say well look
come on
what you're talking about that's not
assimilation that's Erasure
Erasure is the the lib term that that
describes when you disrespect and erase
a different cultural groups and racial
groups is usually how it's applied
which is to say the libs are suggesting
that crime is just an integral part of
certain races and cultures which set
that sounds like the kind of argument
that if we said it they would call that
racist but they're they're the ones who
are saying that and it is not true it is
not true
our society says that though our society
says that good culture is a crime
and that criminal culture is good
our society says that people going to
mass with their families to worship God
on Sunday that that is tantamount to a
crime it's violent extremism it's
terrorism let's go sick the feds on
those Catholics
but people who are committing actual
crimes robberies looting murder that
that's just their culture and we can't
tell anyone that their culture is bad
and we need to let them off the hook and
BLM goes and burns the country down for
eight months well let's let's drop the
charges come on society made them do
that come on actually we supported it
ourselves we Elites running Society
that's where we are completely upside
down Rhonda santis
announced the conclusion of a plan that
he had declared a year ago Ronda santis
is taking self-government away from
Disney
's going to pay its debt and I think if
you remember when we did the initial
special session where we set the Sunset
date and we knew we'd have to deal with
this I always said that they're going to
come in and we're going to we're going
to figure out the best way to do it uh
so so what I said really for the last
six nine months is
Disney is no longer going to have
self-government they're not going to
have their own government Disney is
going to pay its fair share of taxes and
Disney's going to honor the debt and
that's exactly what this proposed piece
of legislation will do if you remember
when we first went down this road last
spring a lot of folks in the media were
saying that oh my gosh Disney's actually
going to pay less taxes and Floridians
are going to pay more taxes they were
saying that and I'm like you've got to
be kidding me well this puts that to bed
and so those debts will be honored and
those will be paid now this is obviously
now going to be controlled by the state
of Florida which is no longer
self-governing for them so there's a new
sheriff in town and that's just the way
it's going to be
really really good look in practice what
this means is that Disney for the last
half century or more has had control of
the local government of the district
that Disney World operates in and what
DeSantis has done is take over the
district take it back from Disney so
Florida Republicans will have DeSantis
appointing all five leaders of Disney's
tax District in Orlando and they will
rename the district so it will no longer
be called the Reedy Creek improvement
district which is what it had been
called it'll now be the central Florida
tourism oversight district and the
reason this matters
for DeSantis in particular is it shows
follow through
it's not just an announcement when he
announced it last year I thought oh this
is a good political stunt this looks
good it's the right idea okay fine
but then he actually followed through
with it he doesn't really get a new
headline out of the announcement
yesterday I mean we're talking about it
some people will talk about it but it's
not a new news story he already
announced that this would happen the
difference is now he's following through
which is important if he is going to run
for president in 2024 it looks like he
is he'll be able to point and say look I
don't just have the right gut instincts
I don't just come out with big
announcements that grab headlines but I
actually follow through with them you
can trust me to do what I am promising
you that I will do the other reason that
this looks really good for Ron DeSantis
is it shows that Ron desantis's
conservatism is a conservatism that is
much more comfortable
wielding state power
than the conservatism of many of the
squishes in the party many people in the
Republican Party especially over the
last 20 years their their conservatism
has amounted to hey I'm not going to do
anything you elect me and I'm just
basically going to go home and I'm not
going to the most I'm gonna do is
deregulate and give corporations more
power and let them do whatever they want
that that was the heavily libertarian
scented
conservative base movement kind of
conservatism in recent years and
the reason that that was attractive to
people is because big government has
done all sorts of bad things and so we
were reacting against that the other
reason is because we had we've just
fought a cold war for the second half of
the 20th century and so opposition to
big government was something that United
a lot of conservatives because our enemy
was the Soviet Union and communism
we are now seeing
some of the excesses in the other
direction when you privatize everything
when you give woke corporations free
reign to do whatever the hell that they
want that also can hurt conservatives if
it's big government taking my rights
that's bad if it's Google taking my
rights that's also bad it's not if it's
Disney transiting my kids that is just
as bad as if Dr fauci were Trancy my
kids or Rachelle wolenski or who's that
guy the guy who is the assistant Health
sector Richard Levine that guy it's just
as bad I I don't care whether it's a
public or allegedly private entity
transiting my kids all I care about is
are my kids being trans are my rights
being taken away is my way of life being
upended and a lot of conservatives just
they're not there yet they don't quite
understand how to articulate why it is a
good thing sometimes to wield state
power against corporations Rhonda santis
can do it he can articulate it and he is
actually doing it and the other
Republicans who want to look good coming
into 2020 four are going to have to get
on the stick at the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member at dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]